i saw courtney and scott asleep together
on the couch
they're definitely made for each other
like they're supposed to be together
yeah so apparently the kardashians think
kourtney kardashian and scott disick
are made for each other abcdefg
i have to go what the heck is abcde of
jimmy
on thursday the trailer for the 20th and
final season of keeping up with the
kardashians dropped and the famous fam
gave their two cents on the x's
after kim spotted them taking a nap
together on the couch
they're definitely made for each other
like they're supposed to be together
yeah so that's all they gave us talk
about a tease
of course scott and court share three
kiddos together eleven-year-old mason
eight-year-old penelope and six-year-old
reign and the two have managed to stay
close and co-parent
ever since their high-profile breakup in
2015.
i think we've been through so much in so
many things and to hear her
be proud of me means you know a ton to
me and since they're split
they've both had their fair share of
other romances
court had a thing with eunice benjamin
and is currently dating her longtime
friend blink 182 drummer
travis barker scott and sophia richie
broke up in 2020
after three years of dating 2020 was
my year of being like letting everything
go and just like no fear
and the 37 year olds recently rang in
the new year in mexico with 19 year old
amelia hamlin a source told et earlier
this month that scott is still dating
amelia
and having fun with her as for the push
founder's new romance with travis barker
the same source says scott is supportive
of it and wants courtney to be happy
and court spam is here for it too
they're all very happy for her and think
this is the healthiest relationship that
she could be in
thank you we'll have to tune in to see
it all go down on the final season of
keeping up with the kardashians when it
premieres march 18th
on e
[Music]